hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einer neuen
episode whatsapp fällt und ich würde
sagen wir fangen mit dem ersten wort
sale bei dem eine person ein handy
gefunden hat und dann eine nachricht
geschrieben hat an die erste person die
ganz oben in der kontaktliste stand und
das war dumm und die person hat
geschrieben reihe fand des von the first
contact little friend found what friends
are one whose name ist ob screen so
kenneth l m klasse das ist deinem
kollegen geschrieben hast egal ob als
macht keinen sinn wenn du es anders
handy schreibt dass er vermehrt kleine
lust auf was fast so was bist du
betrunken was schreibst du mir mitten in
der nacht sollte schon längst zu hause
sein wie zuhause zu mir oder zu dir
jetzt deine mutter jetzt macht sich auf
den weg es ist schon spät
altonas einfach mal irgend so ein random
mädel von der party mit deiner mutter
verwechseln hier bekommen eine person
eine nachricht von seiner freundin und
zwar what would you broke it you get
back mit max know how much i care einem
dann hey you wanna go out what you are
my axe das
das war das war
und ich glaube schon wieder die ganze
zeit hier bekommt einen typ von seinem
kollegen namens dave die nachricht jutsu
jetzt den rest rolle der really need to
present the music was really laut david
and realize tabus listen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ich hab hier oben eine umfrage
reingepackt also stimmt doch bitte gern
mal ab ob ich diese fails immer noch mal
auf deutsch übersetzen soll oder ob das
selbst erklärendes weil ich meine hier
würde ich euch jetzt hat noch sagen ja
oder typ war im restaurant und musste
furzen und dann hat er halt geführt weil
die musik gerade ziemlich laut sondern
ist mal aufgefallen
die musik lief nur bei seine kopfhörer
eigentlich erklärt sich das von selbst
und ich glaube so viel englisch
kenntnisse besitzt jeder aber wenn ihr
sagt nee ich bin blöd ich kann kein
englisch den stürmer gerne ab heute
gesetzlich in der nächsten folge machen
wir jetzt allerdings hier weiter mit
einem deutschen sms verschreibt der
vater seinem sohn du bist 16 existiert
für dich nicht erst nicht real ungefähr
wie der osterhase und du bist
verheiratet für dich existiert er auch
nicht touche mein sohn tu was ist das
eigentlich für ein geiles wort
das bedeutet wenn man sagt man zu stehen
wenn der anderen gutes argument
geliefert hat oder so eine dusche
hier bekommen eine person von seiner
mutter die nachricht als gatte tell you
something you singt i'm actually what's
up your brother sausage dog day to what
we're talking about where you tell me
der text call me die gerade
exterritorial man jetzt wissen auch dass
in amerika mütter nicht so richtig klar
komme der autokorrektur wie gerade aus
dem krankenhaus raus
kreuder träumer oder wie man halt dich
damit tut der ganze nacken während bei
diesem essen erzählen möchte eine person
ein autokauf und schreibt deswegen dem
verkäufer hey james morris wurde tino
weit kommen sagte k you have for sale
after falls gm is good for me when you
are available gebiet beschrieben
available after six tomorrow
dann schreibt allerdings am nächsten tag
good night bvkj way to have you in my
arms love and miss you keep 66 auf
rottmann amtes interesse denn der kann
[Musik]
allerdings zur abwechslung mal zu
einigen watson fans die ihr mir auf
instagram geschickt habt per pm
also wenn ihr eventuell auch in die
nächste folge kommen wollt mit umfeldern
folgt mir und schon streicher sprachen
lernen dass ihr schreibt eine mutter an
ihre tochter fahren jetzt richtung
münchen kannst dich ja mal melden hey
was heißt haye jedoch an wo soll ich ran
gehen und das
ja so die verteilt halt wenn eine mutter
auf das internet trifft ich bin mir
etwas unklare ich jetzt weitermachen so
hier schickt einen typen freundin eine
sprachnachricht und sie antwortet darauf
woher weißt du von meinem asthma aber
irgendwie sowas sondern antwortet er
gelegentliches dort nichts krasses nur
mein körper deinem fenster stehen
[Musik]
mega mega süß das dass er das weiß man
zu nahrung in pi mal daumen samstag war
es in der tat hier fragt ein mädel in
ihren neuen c klassen gruppe was ist
billiger als nudeln und die anderen
antworten keine ahnung und sie schreibt
spaghetti omg
da klatsche ich wirklich nur einmal das
hier ist der nächste wort sale also das
ist wirklich nach hama krasse
unterhaltung und der nächste fehler ist
eine richtige premiere heute in der
zwölften folge ja mittlerweile schon ein
monster ist ein what the hell methoden
eine sprachnachricht wo sich eine person
krass versprochen hat und einen dreher
in den worten drin hatte aber hört
einfach selbst warten jetzt auch nicht
so viel zu tun
ich empfehle dir bei diesem nächsten
whatsapp wurde eine person in die
klassen gruppe 6 den hinzugefügt und
direkt danach wieder entfernt
die haben sich anscheinend richtig lieb
da und hier schreibt eine lehrerin in
die whatsapp klassen gruppe hallo ihr
lieben ich wünsche euch schöne ostern
und hoffe ihr könnt es genießen auch
wenn es anders abläuft als sonst habt
schöne feiertage bis bald und anderen
schreiben einfach alle danke ihnen auf
danke danke gleichfalls danke
gleichfalls danke das war bei uns in den
rezepten und gruppen mit lehrern auch
immer so ist es halt allgemein total
komisch mit seinem lehrer zu schreiben
finde ich
das passt irgendwie nicht was auch nicht
so richtig passt sind solche
sprachnachrichten 19 minuten und 46
sekunden hat sie gesprochen
in der zeit hier antwortet eine person
auf die nachricht schönen valentinstag
an alle die dieses jahr auch single sind
mit der nachricht der junge auf deinem
profil bild ist nicht dein freund
das ist kein junge sorry hab ich mich
wohl ein bisschen versehen und das ist
glaube ich sehr unangenehm diese
nachricht ist allerdings auch ziemlich
unangenehm und zwar grüße dich du hör
mal heute haben drei doch der gefragt
seid mir nicht böse aber ich habe ihnen
deine telefonnummer und adresse gegeben
damit er bescheid weiß die heizung glück
gesundheit und liebe ich möchte dass
diese drei immer an deiner nähe sind
schick des weiteren sieben menschen halt
einfach dein maul und beim nächsten
whatsapp fälle haben wir mal wieder eine
richtig kreative umfangreiche und echte
informative und sind bildliche und echt
super klasse tolle super bombastische
unterhaltung zwischen einer mutter und
ihrer tochter nämlich das ja und beim
nächsten mordfälle haben wir die
erkenntnis des tages und zwar schreibt
sie nach oben gehe ich verstehe es
endlich was denn du weißt ja wenn sachen
heiß sind an denen sie sich aus und ich
bin nicht ich bin heiß
[Musik]
sina da ist die tür kommen nun
allerdings auch schon zu den letzten
beiden fans die ihr mir auf instagram
zugeschickt haben wie bereits gesagt so
ich heiße laser luca also könnte man da
vorbeischauen
die fresse du leute ich schwitze wie ein
warzenschwein weil es so walter hahaha
ich glaube ich bin schlimmer a yamaha
aber weintrauben helfen voll irgendwie
keine ahnung ja ja
ah ja
ja liebe grüße zu dir warzenschwein
und ja wir wieder mal einen klassen
gruppen whatsapp viel von der neuen c
und zwar fragt die person warst du in
südtirol urlaub die nachrichten sind
unzensiert und die person die dort war
antwortet nee italien
ich hoffe ja erdkundelehrer ist auch in
dieser gruppe und schmeiß dich jetzt von
der schule ich weiss ist jetzt ein
bisschen tumult es wird jetzt chris
kaman bei diesem nächsten sms bekommt
eine person von seinem kumpel schon die
frage gestellt die haut rang last night
i hate you can express.de zeigt ob
allerdings auch so langsam zum ende der
heutigen whatsapp fels folge und zwar zu
einer neuen kategorie erfahren sie die
heutige folge voll mit prämieren
ich habe mir auf jeden fall gedacht es
gibt so viele kreative texte die leute
mit angies anfertigen von daher schauen
wo es einmal ein paar an hier zum
beispiel fliegt ein haus hoch da die
person ganz viele luftballons oben dran
gemacht hier hat die personen
geschrieben
zu days night day und hat halt oben zu
wolken gemacht dann eine person die
läuft und dann aus und es kommen tausend
bienen hinter der person her hier
watch me with now they also er hat
diesen bzw sie hat diesen tanz mit
images dargestellt hier ist eine person
ziemlich traurig und weint ein ganzes
meer voll mit seinen tränen und das oft
sogar eine person drauf und das hier ist
der letzte für heute der letzte kreative
im text
ich kann nicht singen aber ds 2080 ich
komme das ist bei den typen just an der
stelle wird die heutige gesunde was dem
fenster beiden werden freunde wenn es
euch gefallen hat das gerne einen daumen
hoch unter die mitte an schreibt mir mal
euren eigenen kreativen texten in die
kommentare
das war schnell und jetzt befinden wir
uns auch im auto hier findet ihr oben
ein smiley eingeblendet wenn ihr noch
kein teil der lupus also von einer
community und ihre noch nicht abonnent
von meinem kanal sein und keine videos
mehr verpassen wollt dann klickt dann
drauf dann ist es kostenlos und dann
seid ihr mit dabei und hier ist ein
video was ich heute auf meinem 2 kanal
hochgeladen habe da habe ich ein video
gemacht und sobald ich das wort sage es
ist vorbei